foreign
set in place like if it if you bring it
to my house if you use whatever then you
no longer live here
so can I just pause for a second
absolutely good for you how do I stand
in that boundary when I feel like it's
being pushed back against me
[Music]
what up what up this is John the Dr John
deloney show
show about your mental and emotional
health
about your family about your love
for yourself for other people your
relationships your marriage your kids
whatever you got going on we talk about
it live here on the show if you want to
be on this show we're talking about
everything whatever you're struggling
with will help you figure out the next
right decision
1-844-693-3291 you're gonna leave a
message and Jenna and Kelly will listen
to them and they will put together a
great show and give you a call back or
go to John deloney.com ask a-s-k so
1-844-693-3291 or go to John delaney.com
ask
and
um I haven't mentioned this in a few
weeks please please take a second to
like the show subscribe to the show if
you're watching this on the tubes please
just hit the Subscribe button it makes
such an enormous difference for your
neighbors who have no idea this show
exists
um Kelly we were in a meeting today
we're talking about the data and this
show continues it it's it's staggering
it's a hundred percent rollover for
every month it's just I mean never see
anything like it every time we get like
month over month it's just tremendous
growth doubles from it uh you know I was
with Blake yesterday and he's like we
don't know you know what to do with it
it just keeps rolling like that and so
because our listeners are amazing
they're incredible and they tell the
friends about it or they send it to
their mother-in-law their mother-in-laws
because everybody thinks their
mother-in-law is a narcissist I don't my
mother-in-law is incredible
you look like there's a I'm just playing
and playing my mother-in-law is always
amazing as well I hit the jackpot she
was fantastic yeah mine too mine too
all right let's uh let's get to the
calls let's go out to Austin Texas the
512 and talk to Katie what's up Katie
Katie you there
here okay sorry you cut out for a second
okay hey what's happening yeah I got you
what's up
um so
um first of all thank you so much this
is awesome I'm super excited also very
nervous so sorry in advance all right
and first of all thank you I'm very
nervous and excited so same same boat
same team we can do it okay
1000 degrees in Texas right now oh my
gosh yeah and I'm eight months pregnant
so no no no
my wife's in Texas right now with my
kids and
she just said it's it's a thousand
degrees yeah what are y'all doing fix
that guys what Fest I don't know eight
months pregnant oh gosh jeez I was like
fun fact guys your shins can sweat
last week at work
Rose I don't know that my shins have
ever sweat but well done
thank you I'm sure I'm sure it's
possible all right so what's up what's
up you Shin sweater that sounds like a
slur
anyway all right what's up
okay
um so about a year ago
um I cut off relationship with my mom
how come
actually a device is two therapists
um at the time
um so
uh
growing up it was a pretty chaotic
um existence my sister has high
functioning autism so but they didn't
know it at the time
um so she was very emotional and needed
a lot of attention
um and just behavior all that and then
my dad avoided being home by being at
work
um
and so it left me at home um pretty much
so I was kind of like the buffer between
my mom and my sister and like any time
my mom was just
pressured by anything it just always was
taken out on me
um and it it so there's just like a lot
of baggage and stuff that went with that
and I was having
really hard time last summer
um and I was actually using better
health so plug for that
um and um
I ended up on better help I started with
a different therapist and then got over
there um but um they're both like you
know I really think
every time you talk to your mom it just
really it doesn't help anything it hurts
um you have a lot of
damage and package there I don't know
how much detail you want to go into in
the backstory of it all um I mean I
trust uh I mean the the salicious side
of me wants to know like what'd she say
what'd she do but I don't think that's
important here you've got two
professional licensed therapists telling
you hey you need to draw some pretty
hard boundaries right and yeah I know in
my world telling somebody to not talk to
their mom there's got you don't just
throw that around right so if two
different therapists have told you that
then I trust I trust you I trust them I
trust everybody that this is where we
are okay okay
um there's just like a lot of
gaslighting and um like everything was
my fault and like everything would be
fine and then just like and I've heard
you talk to other people about this like
you're at home and you'd be doing
something all of a sudden just like
bombs would go off and you have no idea
why and then you're just trying to madly
fix it um and I'm assuming that has
followed you into your adult life
you're pregnant now you got another are
you married
yeah it's married and have a
five-year-old okay so now she wants to
run that relationship too
well yeah and that's part of why I would
cut so frustrated last summer like and
that's what kind
of what kind of and she was like well I
was really worried about your son like I
thought he's going to have a weight
problem I'm like he at no point ever had
a weight problem like I don't know where
you're even getting this and then she'd
always make little comments about my
husband and like
just stuff about my life like anything I
could be like we're going to the grocery
store this weekend she's like are you
can he can are you sure you can handle
that so we're here so we're here now
so we're here now what happened so
um so she I cut off relationships she
sent she has mailed some things
throughout the time but I haven't
responded to them because they were very
cold and disconnected and it was not
sincere at all
um but this last time she sent a letter
and it was like I moved to apologize for
my selfishness
um
like I didn't recognize your needs
struggles and difficulties as a child
and then was like I love you which is
the first time she said that in any of
her Communications she still founded her
first name instead of like Mom or
anything but
my husband's like I think that's the
best apology you're ever gonna get out
of the situation
um which I I agree and it kind of feels
like the ball's in my court now like
either like I need to respond and I I
just don't know if I need to and to me
it was a very passive apology like sorry
you had a hard time over there versus
like sorry I was emotionally abusive
well so so here's like as you're talking
here's the thoughts running through my
mind okay and it's gonna sound like I'm
coming at you I'm not I'm leaning up
against your boundaries too okay okay
um
if you cut her off
to try to get something from her that's
manipulation
that's what it feels like
if you cut her off to protect you and
your family and you really didn't even
have a
unless she does a B or C or D and maybe
you explain that to her
um
that's a totally different story but if
you cut her off and then she's just been
like throwing
um little notes over your giant brick
wall and she's trying to figure out what
note is going to open the door
um then that's that's manipulation
that's that's I mean it's almost like
I'm getting you back Mom and I'm Gonna
Get You Back by taking away your
grandkids and your daughter
totally fair
um
I had no intention of trying like
I've actually honestly I think you
posted this on social media like
pray for they that they have deep
laughter and a great life and like
become whole and feel and I honestly
like I want that for her
I just can't keep putting myself
out of obligation every week because
like I'll be in trouble quote unquote
which I know sounds ridiculous no it
does not I mean it's yes it happens but
so so what what is making you feel like
you have to respond to this
um
when I cut her off like it was honestly
one of the scariest things I've ever
done like you know when your heart beats
like in your jaw and everything hurts
um it was like one of those moments and
I sent an email it wasn't like the most
tactful probably
um and I didn't list any grievances so
it's I don't know if it's fair to be
like why aren't you apologizing for the
things I expected you to apologize for
when you don't know what they are
but I I don't know I want to do the
right thing every you know cutting off
your mom is just such a
huge thing and ever no one understands
it they're like but that's your mom so
it just
I guess I want to they don't get to not
be cruel I don't I don't want to be
cruel I don't want to
be trying to inflict like I'm I'm not
consciously trying to inflict pain I
honestly feel like I've been healthier
mentally
I've been a better mom I've been able to
focus on the therapy like I actually fit
quote unquote finish therapy like to the
point where my therapist is like I don't
know that I need to see you every week
so that's honestly why I don't have her
to talk to right now about it let me
walk through a couple of of choices I
think we've got number one
you told her I'm I'm done I wish you the
best I'm going to pray for you to have
joy in your life but it won't be include
me or your grandkids that's number one
um so think again think of your boundary
you just you just put up a wall and
think of that wall that someone's just
throwing stuff over the wall they can
throw that out that's fine you can't
come over the wall they can throw crap
over all day so that's number one
number two is you can
um respond
by basically opening the little crack
I'm thinking of like a medieval castle
and they just and there's a big thick
wooden door and they just move that
little bitty that little bitty thing at
the beginning you know in the door
that's like a little bitty box it's like
a little bit square and you all you can
see is just your eyes
and you can you could lean out and go
hey I got your note thank you so much
for sending that I wish you the best and
close it back
okay you can do that
if you know your mom I mean you know
your mom about anybody if you do that
that might be a wink to her thank you so
much that your apology meant the world
to me I'm really grateful I wish you the
best
that is I'm not we're not going back to
the old days what I sent you in that
email still stands but I did want to say
thank you like you can do that but you
know your mom for some people
that that would allow their mom some
peace to ride off into the sunset for
some that would be just the crack they
needed to
you know bring a sewage truck and just
start pumping crap through that door
again right and then the third thing is
you go open the door and go running out
and hug your mom in the field and like
you know the the
notebook music starts playing and all
that kind of stuff so you know better
than anybody what I would challenge you
on is
um
don't roll this off on your therapist
they made a recommendation but they
didn't tell you what to do you had to
make the call yeah
um your friends have recommendations
cool
but at the end of the day you have to
live with this and so you and you also
know how your mom's gonna respond so I
want you to feel empowered to do the
right thing for you and your family
and um move forward from there
okay
okay so that's there's not a there's not
a a one-size-fits-all answer here
gotcha like that's why I haven't yet
because I actually received this letter
on Mother's Day I think but
was like the baby coming and last time
when I had a baby she was
so unhelpful and honestly very damaging
at the time so it's like that feels like
walking back into a house that's still
on fire yeah why would I do that
well if you're going back in there to
rescue somebody Maybe
yeah but if you're going back in there
to try to make somebody feel better and
they won't get out of that burning house
too then yeah that's I mean
yeah yep that's it like I just escaped
and and she's one of those people that
will fit in misery to try to bring you
back into it I think you've answered
your own question then
okay yeah well done well done Katie um
for everybody struggling with this kind
of situation like you've put up a
boundary whether it's with um an ex
whether it's with a parent whether it's
with a grandparent whether it's with
um whoever
number one expect that people are going
to try to test that boundary and see if
it's going to hold they're gonna run up
against it they're gonna throw things
over they're gonna send notes or however
they're gonna try to find out is this
boundary gonna hold
number two expect other people to be
upset that that boundary exists because
that boundary disrupts not just the
relationship between you and the person
you're putting the boundary up but it it
affects other people siblings friend
groups uh Church groups everybody in
between
the third thing is there may come a
season when that boundary doesn't serve
you anymore and we're ready to move on
but for right now it's gonna stay or
whatever or I'm gonna give you a number
four I'm gonna give you an ultimatum
these things have to happen or this
boundary goes up great
we talked about on on a previous
show if you
um 80 year old man kiss my teenage
daughter after she's asked you and I've
asked you not to then um we don't come
around
if you're there we leave we leave
and if you drive down or fly down to my
house
and you knock on my door and you say I
am so sorry that I violated the Dignity
of your family
but way more importantly I value the
Dignity of your bodily autonomy and the
autonomy of your daughter and I'm sorry
it will never happen again thank you for
calling me out on my abusive Behavior
um it will never happen again in fact
I'll be the chief advocate for you and
your family and nobody's gonna put your
hands on
then maybe you say cool we can open this
door and give it a shot that's totally
up to you
I just want people who put up boundaries
boundaries are hard to put up you put up
a boundary feel a piece you've done the
right thing
you're going to feel guilty you're going
to feel ashamed you're gonna feel those
things if you feel they need to put up a
boundary put it up
put it up and hold to it good for you
Katie I'm proudy we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com deloney today to
get 10 off your first month that's a
better help h-e-lp p.com slash deloni
all right let's go out Oklahoma great
let's go to Oklahoma and talk to Stacy
what's up Stacy
hi Dr John what's up
oh not much so
that's the most Oklahoma answer not much
everyone in my family died that's right
exactly I know it
So speaking of boundaries if we are all
right let's do it so I have been in a
relationship with my fiance for about
three years
he has a 15 year old son he's had a
history of addiction
um he has
about eight months ago came and lived
with us but there was there there were
rules set in place like if it if you
bring it to my house if you use whatever
then you no longer live here
so can I just pause for a second yes
absolutely good for you
good for you your own kids yes so we
also share
um an hour's child that is 14 months old
okay
an hour's
child's child because he he has his
stepson
my stepson 21st century label we have an
hour's son and a there we have an hour's
child so we do have a baby we're good
okay go for it which so about eight
months ago
he asked to come to our house and stay
there he wanted to come live with us so
this boundary was set in place
now that about three weeks ago he almost
died of a fentanyl overdose in my
bathtub
when nobody was home and the cops had to
come kick the door down I have said
you're not living here anymore
that was my boundary good for you what I
need to know is how do I stand in that
boundary when I feel like it's being
pushed back against me like now that
it's actually happened and I've set that
ultimatum in place to say no this is
where my daughter lives you were told
what the consequences would be now you
have done that you don't get just to
just say she just doesn't want me living
there because she's mean and she doesn't
like me the the 15 year old doesn't get
a vote
yeah that's right fiance is pushing back
yeah first of all he's he enables him
you know he purchases his nicotine
he lets him use THC Infuse CBD because
of his quote anxiety well he's had way
too much leash to begin with as far as
I'm concerned but this was the boundary
set in place when you came to live with
us
this has now happened you're out all
right Stacy that's the easy part that's
the easy part yeah your problem is not
with this 15 year old boy your problem
the 15 year old boy is the proxy war
yeah your problems with this guy you're
dating
here's what I think I think he told you
things are going to be different and you
you get to have a lot of influence over
your little girl do you all live
together
we do okay so you you get to have a lot
of influence over this little girl's
life and your husband goes along with it
yeah and he doesn't like to say no to
anybody whether it's you or his 15 year
old oh that's absolutely the truth and
now you are getting to see in real time
holy crap this is who this guy actually
is right and it's really gross
oh it's it's bad I mean it's physically
the
the physical anxiety that I get when
when this when he is around
is debilitating I mean it's the number
one problem in our relationship I mean
he has to disagree disagree prescription
was not he's not the biggest problem the
biggest problem in your relationship is
you and your fiance
right it's just a point of contention I
guess I should say it's true but the
bigger contention is your husband's
choosing his child which I'm gonna go
and say until y'all are married he
should be he should oh absolutely
absolutely and I agree with that and
but you have another child to protect as
well that's right and he's not and that
is my child and not I mean nothing will
happen to her yes I mean literally Over
My Dead Body it's not gonna happen I
mean he has stolen money prescription
drugs
my friends he's a 15 year old with
addiction
right and now that it's to the point
that it has reached like maximum level
like my my boundary is she and I will
not be around him but Stacy every six
years you're trying to convince me I'm
with you I know why are you trying to
convince me same team because for three
weeks this has been my life day in a day
out like just constantly I would quit
having the conversation because you're
making yourself insane
oh I know I am the conversation's over
yeah if now here's what this gets ugly
and messy and messy and ugly
you can look at your fiance and say if
you need to be with him I understand but
it won't be in this house
yes then that conversation needs that I
just have not said those words it needs
to happen because you're both dancing
around it
yeah all of his excuses are you know he
needs us and it's a place for him to be
here than his mom and he does he needs
that but I don't want to drug drug my
infant or my toddler through the trauma
that I'm gonna have to cancel out of her
later if she finds her brother dead
there you go
this is exactly where we are I mean he
almost died in our bathtub luckily his
girlfriend was there to call an
ambulance but
other the alternative would have been
Stacy I find him
I know it's just exhausting Dr John it
is but you are exhausting yourself
I know okay I'm gonna tell you something
crazy but you got to be my friend after
I tell it to you because I'm gonna tell
you straight
I will there's a great uh psychiatrist
he's he's um he's probably in his 90s
now
um his name is Urban yallum
and he um it was is he's known for
existential psychology he's known for
all these great things but he is the
thing I think he's most known for in my
soul is he is a trainer of counselors
and he said
um something that stuck with me when I
was first training I was really young
into this mental health practitioner
thing and he said in a counseling
situation in an interaction with
somebody
everything is data
everything is data what here's what that
means
um we're not you and I are not an
accounting relationship but we're
talking about what's the next right step
right right
he said if you're talking to somebody as
a therapist or as a coach and you find
yourself so unable to continue to pay
attention because the other person is so
boring probably
their wife experiences that and their
co-workers experience that and they
start to tune them out and shut them off
and that makes him nuts
and so call that out or if somebody is
smells really really top like it's
really rough and that means everyone
else in their life experiences that too
and so the idea was not only the things
that somebody's saying is everyone's
date is is data but how they how they
feel when you're interacting with them
okay so I tell you all that to say
I can feel
how bottled up this stuff is and how
machine gun fire and exhausting it all
is
oh my gosh yes
because I'm going I really want to do is
just be her mama I don't want to there
you go this is just it's so much it
really is just so much but you keep
bringing gasoline back to the fire
stop just stop you have made your
decision you are right
and I'm gonna I'm gonna go one step
further
I wouldn't
um if this was just about
a little boy who's struggling and I'm
gonna say a 15 year old this little boy
here a a child who is struggling with
addiction who is close to overdosing who
I that wouldn't be the reason
but I know and you know a kid struggling
with this type of opioid addiction who's
got a a mom whose home is not safe he's
got a dad with No Boundaries who's
stolen from family stolen from Friends
stolen from community members that's the
behavior I don't want my daughter around
correct I don't mind my children around
hurting people if there's adults to
regulate that interaction
you all don't have that because you have
an enabling adult
yeah and it is it is beyond just a
hurting person it's a person who's now
inflicting harm in other people
that's what I'm going to separate my
daughter from I have no problem doing
that
problem y'all gonna run into is y'all
built the life together you created a
kid together you've been together for
three years and now there's a fracture
and you'll have to address the reality
of that fracture and blaming this 15
year old kid blaming I gotta protect my
baby all that's true but that's on the
outside what's on the inside is I don't
love a man who is so weak he won't help
his 15 year old son
I don't love a man who is so incapable
of helping his son
they're just going to watch him die in
our bathtub for God's sake
I don't love a man who's so weak he's
just gonna put our four-year-old
daughter In Harm's Way like this
and like you mentioned even if the boy
is okay he's got girlfriends showing up
he's got a dealer showing up who knows
coming to your house all I have to say
is you are right
but the they aren't the problem the
problem is you have now had a
um a new pair of glasses with which to
view the man you're engaged to and you
don't like what you say
I know that's what you got to deal with
Fair yeah
yeah I'm sorry that's okay I mean I
wouldn't have called if I didn't think
you were going to just tell me straight
though I hate that well I I well but I
don't want to pretend that I don't that
this isn't change everything
oh yeah
it does if yeah the whole thing's a mess
I get that I'm so sorry I I mean I just
hate that for everybody
for everybody I will say this
I don't think that that your marriage is
is irredeemable I don't think this 15
year old boy is irredeemable
I don't think any healing happens until
somebody you've heard me say this but
somebody turns the lights on stops the
music and says this dance is over here's
reality from this point forward
and then people get to make adult
decisions and opt in or out and that 15
year old may get the boundaries that he
needs desperately to survive
um or
he's gonna die under somebody else's
roof because you are not going to sit
down and watch this happen no
absolutely right Fair
absolutely Fair
I hate this for you I'm sorry I know
that's okay I'd give you some
conversation cards but that just feels
like I'm kicking you while you're down
right yeah
not ready yet no I was I was playing
um oh geez all right well let me know
how I can help anyway as we as you move
forward through this and we'll be
thinking about you man
um
this is one of those calls that I you
can't button up with happily ever after
this is just a lot of really hard
boundaries and really a lot I mean a lot
of hard conversations
and there's probably a lot of hurt and a
lot of tears and especially initially
as you say
as for me in my house me and my baby
girl we're gonna be safe and it doesn't
include this
thank you for the call Stacy call
anytime anytime anytime we'll have you
back we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right we are back let's go out to
Hampton Virginia
and talk to the great DJ what's Up DJ
hey how are you good oh good I thought
it was DJ Jazzy Jeff and The Fresh
Prince it is not thank goodness no it is
DJ laryngitis going on right now
excellent
I sound like I'm the one that's been
partying but I have not been you have DJ
and it's okay it's a safe space on the
show I don't even think the show is
quite a safe space but hey you're good
you're good we will we will pull up a
seat for somebody with laryngitis no
problem what's up thank you
um okay so my my question is what do I
do now
um but obviously you could have a little
bit of background
um so long short of it I I met a great
man
um through a mutual friend he was in the
middle of a messy divorce so I did not
pursue anything
um and we uh I was there more of a
supportive role we kind of realized we
liked each other and we saw each other
about every
um every two weeks given my custody
Arrangement and um in his you know
during his separation so we are three
months after his um divorces final and
um you know this has been almost a year
now that we've been talking and been
there for each other and I'm just
wondering
um
I brought up intentions and
um that I wanted to build something
significant with someone and was
wondering if he saw that potential for
us
and along with that would be you know
introducing our children eventually and
not you know not for a while still and
um just kind of wondering uh you know
what do I do now just step back and
keep the ball in his court and let him
figure out what he wants and uh go from
there how long have you been divorced
um let's see my son's four and a half so
we've been divorced
um it's been over two years but we've
been separated since my son was almost a
month old okay
is this your first
time you've been dating or is this just
the first time you've dated somebody and
you're like I don't like this guy
first time tried online dating
really don't recommend it
um but yeah this is the first
um guy that you know is is really just a
wonderful man and you know when I see
these things it's we have the same
morals we grew up the same way with you
know in a Christian home and we have
similar values on with how we want to
raise our children and uh he's kind and
you know chemistry is there too so it's
all the good things
um what what I know he's going through a
lot yeah what's what's the
do you feel this
um
and again I'm not saying this like
talking down I'm saying it's like just
imagine you and I are sitting at a table
and we're both cracking up okay
all right do you feel like okay I've
been on on gosh the words I'm using here
are really obnoxious and so just for the
Casual listeners I'm being obnoxious on
purpose
do you okay you've been on the market
for two years and you see this guy and
you're like these guys don't come around
and so I want to lock it down
or do you feel like a soul connection
with somebody after a year
like what what's what's the rush to not
just have a great time for the next year
laughing and carrying on and going on
dates and being goofy and playing
pickleball and going to concerts and
whatever
yeah you know there is no rush because
I've checked the boxes in my life I've
gotten married I've had a child team
with him you know we don't want more
children we've talked about these things
and yeah yeah yeah there is no rush no
I'm 39. I'm I'm done
oh sister when you sit in this seat the
dog
it's good
um you know and he does feel like
somewhat of a unicorn just because of um
you know meeting all the marks I mean
goodness being able to agree with
someone on the way you raise children
that's that's hard enough as it is
um so I I get I 100 get that
my concern for you is
in your words messy divorce
it was just it was ugly for him
um his wife started seeing a neighbor
and around this person
um before he ever knew it was even going
on
and then there was no um custody fight
and a whole mess separating this thing
yes sir yeah so I think there's gonna
have to be some trauma processing on his
side
because the person he went all in on
took his chips that he cashed in on the
table and handed him to the neighbor
and then quite literally fought him over
it
and bargained with the kids
yeah yeah it was terrible right so he's
been through it and he's gonna have a
physiological reaction to it what I
don't want for you is you to be a safe
like warm place to land for a minute
right until he can catch his breath and
then be like all right now because
you're gonna get really hurt in that
process
oh yeah so I think you are super Super
Wise to say hey I'm I am I'm being
honest I'm going all in I'm taking a
risk
I've got long-term intentions here
but also
he needs to have the space to say I I
yeah I want to love somebody again but
right now my face is still burned from
what just happened
right right and I don't think either one
of those two things means anything other
than
cool we're just gonna be able to hang
out and have fun
and he's awesome and you think he's a
smoke show that's all good I I I'm just
I'm worried about him if he called my
show and said
I just went through a really messy
divorce in the process I met someone
who's awesome my first words to him
would be slow down
yeah that'd be my first words to him
right and at the same time I also know
you're like oh dude the Unicorn I love
how you said that because that's you
being honest
I've got a couple of folks of people's
people who I love who are divorced and
recently divorced or going through the
process and their experience is very
much like your experience like I
oh I did not know Humanity was like this
yeah it's really it's really
disappointing
um but you know I I just don't I don't
have any rush into
wanting to like I need to be in a
relationship or I need someone in my
life and I've told him that I was like
look I don't need you but but I want you
in my life that's awesome that's a
perfect thing to say I love that I love
that and I don't want you to get
devastated if he says I want you in my
life but we're gonna do it real real
slow
or I just want to hold hands with
somebody that's not going to stab me in
the back or I just want to
smooch somebody that's not you know I
mean like I I just I want to go to
movies and and do whatever that
like just the slow play in I I just I
just I don't know I think that just
feels right right now
yeah
I gotcha
and it is disappointing because it'd be
awesome if he was like I'm free from an
evil person and you DJ you laryngitis
and all will you marry me
and that'd be cool
yeah good for you
it took it went through a nasty um
divorce myself from an alcoholic and I'm
still dealing with you know him and his
issues but
um you know the limited amount of time
we have to see each other I have my son
um have primary custody and he spends
one overnight with his dad every other
week so
um it's made me take things slow which
is great that's really great that's
awesome awesome awesome
good for you
um
yeah I think the best thing I think I
think the best thing okay to still
initiate oh I mean I think the best
thing to do is to be authentic and and
upfront and honest and really press him
to be upfront honest too
right okay
and I think it's important to call out
both of y'all are burn victims at this
point
yeah similar hurts yeah you got some
more hurts and so give each other
permission to say wow my body is going
full trauma mode right now my body is
going full Run for the Hills right now
and that doesn't mean anything about DJ
or about him that means you got a body
that's just saying hey we've been down
this road before remember and almost got
us killed how about we don't do that
yeah and yeah the only way towards
laughter and peace and fun is to go
right through it again and
you if this thing works
you're gonna have to open your heart and
be vulnerable to another guy and he
could yeah
Scorch you and vice versa
and so you're gonna have to practice and
slow play that
it's gonna be scary and it could be
awesome
I think almost everything that's worth
it is scary right always always
and
it sounds that sounds good on Instagram
and scary things kill you too right they
they destroy everything so I think
that's that's the great the great of
life is
all the good stuffs man on the other
side of the storm all the good stuff's
on the other side of ah
and
there's bears and tigers on the other
side of the storm too right it's both in
so it's I'm gonna get a group of people
to go with me through this thing you
know what if I had one piece of wisdom
for you and him it would be to make sure
y'all have
a couple of people in your life that's
not each other that will just hang out
go get nachos and a beer go hang out do
just do whatever
um that there is not going to be all of
this pressure to make this thing your
only friendship
um that would be really helpful and
you'll have somebody to talk to I like
him I like him he can be like I think
he'll like her and their butt your
buddies can be like you're crazy or or
not whatever but I think having some
people in your life just to walk with
you just to be your friends just to be
your friends hang out have fun
um
but I'll tell you this
talk to a lot of people in the situation
and you're about as wise as they come DJ
good for you thank you for being honest
and upfront and best of luck to you guys
um holler at me anytime if I can help
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as you wrap up today's show I
want to thank you guys for being with us
um don't forget to send this episode out
to people that you think will will
benefit from it or will enjoy it don't
forget to like And subscribe and all
those ways that you tell the internets
that you are down with this show thanks
for riding with us I'm super super
grateful for y'all
um song of the day is um from Jenna's
second favorite band
um her first favorite band actually it's
her ninth favorite band because her
first eight favorite bands are all
Taylor Swift her ninth favorite band
and her first tattoo on the back of her
neck kind of a weird place to go she
went all in on the first one from the
great Ed Sheeran it just says Ed in big
red block letters not weird at all and
there's a barcode right underneath it
she did that too
um songs called boat off his new record
and it goes like this
came in for the Embers
stayed out for the breeze I need to feel
elements to remind me there's a beauty
when it's bleak
stuck out long before lights down why do
I breathe oh I know
the more that I love the less that I
feel the times that I jumped never were
real they say that all scars will heal
but I know
maybe I won't
but the waves won't rot won't break my
boat
the waves won't break my boat I love
that see you guys soon take care stay in
school don't do drugs or smoke
cigarettes
[Music]